Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Da haben es drei Aufsteiger bisher geschafft, für auch positive Geschichten zu sorgen. Damit wollen wir uns heute befassen, hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 248. Ich begrüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wie schon angekündigt, widmen wir uns heute der 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Zeit wird es. Und heute haben wir eine Aufsteigerrunde hier. Deshalb begrüße ich hier bei mir Anna Lautenbach von der Plattform 210 und dem Eintracht Braunschweig-Podcast Gegengerade. Sie ist die Edrosa Laut. Wer ihr nicht folgt auf allen solchen Mieterplattformen, der hat sie nicht mehr alle. Und sie hat dann dementsprechend nicht alle Follower. Das war jetzt komisch. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du hier bist. Ebenfalls hier, ihr kennt ihn vom Podcast Neues vom Krügelplatz. Ihr kennt ihn aus dem NDR und auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk. Er ist der Ed Leisteo und dieses Akronym steht für Oliver Leiste. Hallo Olli, schön, dass du hier bist. Wir werden heute über Magdeburg sprechen und seitdem ich diese Tasse habe. Das war, glaube ich, unsere erste Folge, wo ich immer noch Magdeburg gesagt habe und du zu höflich warst, mich zu korrigieren. Und dann hat mir ein Hörer eine – es heißt Magdeburg – Tasse geschickt.
Es ist auch überraschend, dass der Trainer Dieter Hecking vom Sportdirektor Dieter Hecking zusammengestellten Kader sagt, der ist doch eigentlich prima.
Das ist klar, aber da entscheidet sich ja dann auch der Fortgang seiner Karriere mit dieser Aussage und mit dieser Konstellation. Bielefeld finde ich sehr spannend. Uwe Koschinert ist ein Trainer, den ich sehr mag, der jetzt auch schon lange in der dritten Liga gearbeitet hat, den ich deswegen immer im Blick hatte. Das ist ein Macher, würde ich sagen, und ein Typ, der in der Mannschaft mitreißen kann. Und vielleicht ist das der Faktor, was Amina Bielefeld jetzt braucht, um da unten rauszukommen. Ich wäre ehrlich gesagt nicht traurig, wenn Sandhausen und Regensburg sich in die dritte Liga verabschieden. Das ist jetzt auch so eine persönliche Präferenz, wo ich denke, in der zweiten Liga fallen sie vom ganzen Umfeld, von der Stimmung und so jetzt schon ein bisschen ab. Das sind jetzt keine Standorte, wo man denkt, wenn man gegen die spielt, boah krass, heute Regensburg oder so. Da freut man sich irgendwie auf einen netten Nachmittag. Sandhausen genauso.
Ja, aber was wird denn dann das neue Sandhausen? Weil immer, wenn jemand in der ersten Liga kurz vor dem Abstieg steht, dann heißt es ja, oh je, nächstes Jahr müssen sie nach Sandhausen fahren. Was würde denn dann das neue Sandhausen sein, frage ich dich?
Der SV Elbersberg, der aus der dritten Liga dabei ist.
Ein klarer Punkt für dich, hast du recht.
Ne, und Magdeburg habe ich gesagt, da denke ich, oder da bin ich recht optimistisch. Fürth hat sich da jetzt auch ein bisschen rausgearbeitet. Spannend finde ich Hannover 96. Da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob die nicht nochmal unten reinrutschen. Ich meine, die haben jetzt schon 30 Punkte, aber sie haben in der Rückrunde, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, eben auch erst ein Unentschieden geholt. Und da ist die Stimmung, soweit ich das aus der Ferne betrachten kann, ja auch sehr, sehr negativ gerade. Da bin ich gespannt, ob es für die vielleicht nicht nochmal eng wird. Wie gesagt, wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte, würde ich sagen, Sandhausen und Regensburg können da bleiben, wo sie stehen. Und der Rest wird sich irgendwie retten.
Also zwei Unentschieden waren es. Aber für Hannover kommt jetzt dann eben das Spiel gegen Nürnberg und dann das Derby gegen Braunschweig. Ich meine, Annas Meinung zu Hannover müssen wir da jetzt nicht einholen. Vermutlich kommen wir uns zumindest… Genau, so ist es. Richtig, da bin ich eine Zeile verrückt. Danke, Olli. Moritz, du kannst ja am entspanntesten von allen draufgucken, aber hast du Gedanken zu den Sachen, die jetzt Olli hat? Es war ja wunderschön, Olli. Hast du sie einfach durch den kompletten Keller einmal durchgeführt, haben wir die volle Führung bekommen. Welche Ecken hat er noch nicht ausgeleuchtet, der Olli, Moritz?
Ich kann ihm bei einer Sache zustimmen, und ich weiß, dass dieser Satz, den ich jetzt sagen werde, gemein ist. Aber wenn ich die 2. Liga als Gesamtbild betrachte, dann verdrägt die 2. Liga nicht Sandhausen und Elbersberg.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen schwarz-weiß, denke?
Bei wem ich persönlich sehr skeptisch bin, ist der 1. FC Nürnberg. Ich drücke ihm natürlich die Daumen, dass er in dieser Liga bleibt, weil der 1. FC Nürnberg – ich hoffe wirklich, dass ihm dieses 3. Liga Bad davon verschont bleibt. Aber ich sehe da so ein bisschen, wenn man sich die Vergangenheit anschaut, natürlich auch die Parallelen, die der FCK irgendwo mal durchgemacht hat, mit größeren Ambitionen und seine Ziele Jahr für Jahr verfehlt. Jetzt haben wir diese Saison mit dem zweiten Trainerwechsel. Wir haben über die Art und Weise der Trainerwechsel gerade schon gesprochen. Ich glaube, die Entscheidung zu Markus Weins hier würde Dieter Hecking jetzt mit dem Wissen von heute auch anders treffen. Ja, es wird schwierig für Nürnberg. Ich glaube auch, dass jetzt – Freitagabend gegen Braunschweig, richtig? Das könnte auch schon so einen kleinen Fingerzeig geben, in welche Richtung es für die Nürnberger geht. Ansonsten, ich glaube, zum FCK brauchen wir da unten nicht mal reden. Also auch wenn dieses ominöse 40-Punkte-Ziel jetzt seit einigen Wochen nicht erreicht wird, runterrutschen tun sie auf gar keinen Fall mehr.
Was für ein absurder Satz eigentlich am 23. Spieltag. Seit einigen Wochen haben wir ja das 40-Punkte-Ziel nicht erreicht mit dem FCK. Also das ist wirklich – ja, man auf dem allerhöchsten Niveau. Aber das weißt du ja. Anna, wie blickst du auf den Tabellenkeller? Du darfst doch gerne über Hannover 96 sprechen. Wir wissen ja, dass uns bekannte Hannover 96-Fans sowieso jetzt zuhören, weil du hier zu Gast bist.
Ja, ich wohne ja in diesem Hannover. Das wissen wahrscheinlich auch die meisten. Ich habe ein durchaus ambivalentes Verhältnis zu dem Verein, weil natürlich ist es der ewige Derby-Gegner. Und ich pflege diese Rivalität auch gerne persönlich, traditionsbewusst und leidenschaftlich. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja in meinem privaten Umfeld auch Menschen, die ich gern habe. Die 96 Fans sind so eine kleine Schnittmenge. Und denen wünsche ich diesen Kummer wirklich überhaupt nicht. Nichtsdestotrotz, bei aller Folklore, ich verstehe schon den Gedanken dahinter. 96 hat zwei Unentschieden geholt. Die Stürmer sind in der Formenkrise Ziele, ist nicht so gut wie in der Hinrunde. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das nicht besonders rühmlich wird für den Verein in der Rückrunde. Vor allem, weil sie eben kein Ziel mehr haben. Die werden nicht mehr aufsteigen. Ich glaube, der Kader geht auch 200 Prozent davon aus, dass das nicht passieren wird, dass man da unten ernsthaft nochmal wirklich in Gefahr gerät. Also, für was genau soll man schwitzen am Spieltag? Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das zu diesem Zeitpunkt in der Saison einen relevanten Unterschied machen kann, diese Motivationsfrage. Nürnberg finde ich den noch besseren Pick aus dem Grund, weil ich glaube, dass diese in Anführungszeichen großen Vereine im Abstiegskampf einfach sehr unter Stress stehen. Deswegen würde ich auch Arminia Bielefeld mal schauen, was der Trainerwechsel in welcher Richtung bewirkt oder nicht bewirkt. Aber sie sind gerade aus der Bundesliga abgestiegen. Da kann sich das Umfeld auch geduldig geben. Ich denke schon, dass man da insgeheim andere Ansprüche hat, wenn man von oben kommt, als sich mit der 3. Liga auseinanderzusetzen. Und mit diesem Druck umzugehen, dafür ist nicht jeder Spieler und dafür ist auch nicht jeder Kader gedacht, weil sie auch nicht dafür zusammengestellt worden sind. Ich denke nicht, dass Hacking den Kader zusammengestellt hat, in dem Bestreben, irgendwie die Klasse zu halten. Und das kann dann schwierig werden, wenn diese Typen auf eine Situation treffen, in der sie sich nicht wohlfühlen, weil sie sie nicht kennen. Was wiederum der komische Vorteil von den beiden aktuell Letzten sein könnte. Weil in Regensburg und Sandhausen man eben einfach so in Ruhe vor sich hinarbeiten kann. Ohne dass es richtig viele Leute stört oder freut. Wir Braunschweiger werden bis zum Mai da mit unten rum schwimmen. Da bin ich leider relativ sicher.
Und ist das nicht krass, dass wir jetzt über den Abstiegskampf sprechen und St. Pauli gar nicht mehr nennen müssen, weil die halt einfach in sechs Spielen der Rückrunde einen Punkt mehr geholt haben als in der kompletten Hinrunde. Und jetzt im Grunde auch so gut wie raus sind mit 14 Punkten Vorsprung. Die haben ja das gemacht, was alle sich immer wünschen. Einfach quasi nochmal mit einem neuen Kartendec starten und dann durchziehen. Aber das ist schon wirklich verrückt. Und da wollte ich nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen. Falls ihr das nicht so genau mitbekommen habt, liegt daran. Die haben jetzt einfach alles gewonnen. Auch neue Trainer und so weiter. Kann also auch funktionieren.
Habe ich gehört, dass sie es normalerweise andersrum machen. Oder andersrum. Letzte Saison war es, glaube ich, so. Da haben sie ja in der Hinrunde alles kaputt geschossen. Waren, glaube ich, sogar Herbstmeister, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall oben richtig gut mit dabei. Noch bis in den März, April rein. Und dann plötzlich da irgendwie den Halt verloren. Dann gefühlt kein Spiel mehr gewonnen bis Saisonende. Und das dann diese Saison erstmal weitergemacht. Einmal den Trainer getauscht und plötzlich fangen sie wieder an zu gewinnen.
Das ist der Fluch der Halbserien, genau. St. Pauli, letzte Saison mit 7 Punkten Vorsprung. Damals auf dem Relegationsplatz ist man tatsächlich Herbstmeister geworden. Naja, aber immerhin, Abstieg wird es nicht mehr. Wir grüßen sehr herzlich alle St. Pauli-Fans. Und wir werden uns angucken, wie sich das so weiter in der 2. Liga entwickelt. Mehr oder weniger entspannt. Aber ihr habt ja im Grunde schon alles dazu gesagt, was man wissen muss. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mal ausführlicher auf die 3 Aufsteiger zu gucken. Wird mich auch interessieren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie ihr das jetzt gefunden habt. Wir haben es jetzt diesmal ein bisschen anders gemacht, diesen 2. Liga Kurzpass. Gebt uns gerne Feedback dazu unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Und jetzt danke ich sehr, sehr herzlich der Ed Rosa Laut, Anna Lautenbach. Man kann dich bei der Gegend gerade hören, werde ich alles verlinken. Danke dir, liebe Anna, dass du im Rasenfunk warst.
Danke für die Einladung, Max.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und schön war es auch, dass Oliver Leiste mal wieder hier war. Beim Neues vom Krügelplatz hört man ihn über Magdeburg sprechen. Als edleisteo kann man ihm folgen. Danke dir, Olli, dass du im Rasenfunk warst. Und danke an Moritz Kreilinger vom Kicker der EDM-Kreilinger, der total entspannt über der Liga thront und sich wundert, warum diese Visionen auf einmal alle so positiv sind. Danke dir, lieber Moritz, dass du hier im Rasenfunk warst.
War ein schönes Gespräch mit euch.
Ja, das fand ich allerdings auch. Und ich hoffe, die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback und hört gerne im Rasenfunk rein. Und unterstützt den Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns und auch die Gäste, Honorare, die wir zahlen, ausschließlich über eure freiwilligen Zahlungen. Und das, was ihr uns gebt, das geht unter anderem in Annika Becker. Die soll zur Frauen-WM für uns reisen nach Australien. Also es gibt mehrere gute Gründe, uns zu unterstützen, auf rasenfunk.de. Support das Club, erfahrt ihr genau, wie es geht. Danke an alle, die das jetzt tun, nach diesem Aufruf. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao!